civilization six releases tomorrow Scott
Butterworth and you have played a full
match probably about twelve hours you'd
say at this point yeah well I played a
full 500 turns so yeah it took about 12
hours and you won though you got a score
victory correct I did yeah I was like
pursuing both culture and science
through most of the game because a lot
of those technologies went hand in hand
so I was the leader for both but I
wasn't able to complete either one so I
just won by score and so this isn't like
a review in progress like we normally do
we want to do ask the reviewer because
this is a massive game obviously
civilization there's theater games that
people play for like hundreds of hours
yeah
myself I plates two five like I don't
know 400 something and I'm sure you know
you played a lot of the civilization
games as well so you're reviewing it we
just wanted to do an early impressions
right now because we just got code like
a day before review embargo essentially
yeah I mean literally I've only
completed one full game like you said in
the final bill and we've been seeing the
game for months leading up to today so
we know quite a bit about it but yeah
this is our first time playing the final
build of the game and yeah I beat it I'd
be one full game which was about 12
hours a game play so there's a lot to
wrap your head around there's a lot just
that I've learned from this one
playthrough that I will apply to future
playthroughs that will kind of determine
how much I actually enjoy the experience
in the end once I've like learned all
these important lessons from failing
during my first my first attempt at the
game exactly that's like part of the
process for these games and so I want to
sort like broad strokes how did that
playthrough feel I mean so they've added
a lot they've changed a lot but Civ is
still Civ it is one of the most
engrossing experiences I mean I assume
people watching this video already know
what Civ is but if you happen to stumble
into this
it's a classic Forex strategy game you
know it's all about building a
civilization from the ground up founding
cities building units exploring the
world trying not to be slaughtered by
your neighbors and so it's it's the kind
of game that's just it's the epitome of
just one more turn just one return to
home return I was here in the office
until 3:30 a.m. last night yeah kind of
on accident like kind of on purpose
because I knew that I needed to play as
much of the game as possible looked up
and realized I should probably be
sleeping yep it was absolutely what I
mean that's such a cliche but I mean
that is quite literally what happened
yeah and so Civ is still Civ despite the
changes and ennum had so happy to report
that you know I think people will
in the series we'll have find a lot of
like the classic pillars still intact
veteran players will find new things to
love but still feel that this is at its
core a civilization game so of the major
changes how do those feel like the
unstacking cities to active research the
hidden agendas with leaders has those
like affected your playthrough as much
as their supposedly supposed to alright
let's talk about those in order so the
unstacking Sidious was probably the
biggest change in the way you play the
game moment-to-moment it used to be that
you kind of got to focus on macro level
strategy right you kind of picked the
technologies you're pursuing you set up
some structure that you're building in a
city and you kind of let it go and you
let it run with unstacking the cities
each turn becomes a lot more active you
have a lot more to kind of manage and
plan in the short term you have to be
looking five and ten turns ahead instead
of just 100-150 turns ahead I mean you
you still only be looking down further
into the future but because the way the
cities are now set up you really manage
things in a different way for example
there's now amenities and housing so
there used to be like global happiness
and global food levels that has now been
shrunk to a much more micro level and
it's managed on an individual city basis
as opposed to like your civilization as
a whole right so a lot of the game was
oh man like I'm running out of space to
expand in this city I have to provide
more housing or this the city will
stagnate and I won't the production will
stop and it won't continue to grow or
other people are becoming unhappy
because there aren't enough amenities I
have to build something to keep them
happy so that I can then build the stuff
that's going to advance the civilization
as a whole it really shifts the focus of
your moment-to-moment investment in the
game and there all these adjacency
bonuses with the unstacked city tiles
right I mean you'll get bonuses from
putting on a campus district next to
mountains I believe so when you get an
astronomy tower or something like this
is all like kind of just general terms
but then like there's so much to learn
about like you don't want to take that
space up for like a hundred turns later
when you want to put an industrial oh my
god this is one of those important
lessons I learned if just not knowing
necessarily what a building's gonna
require cuz they're a bunch of buildings
there you know legacy they've just been
in the game for ever and now kind of
have new not requirements necessarily
but but benefits from from certain
adjacencies and things like that and I
didn't I didn't know that in every case
and so I had to like demolish certain
hexes it so I could build something
somewhere specific or in some cases
actually couldn't build what I needed to
build because I had already placed
something in a position that where it
couldn't be removed or demolished and it
was just like oh I can't build this
thing in the city now I have to find
somewhere else to build this so yeah you
really have to be planning ahead and
it's a little unfortunate coming into it
and not knowing what each and every one
of those is first time through because I
kind of screwed myself without realizing
it and that's it's no oh well but now
and now I know for the future but yeah
there's just a lot more nuance I mean I
think overall what they've kind of done
is focused on the truly important
aspects of the game but dived really
deep into them so they've kind of
eliminated or pared down some of the
really ancillary stuff but other things
they have streamlined but made deeper
that's that's so generic and it's such a
general explanation but I think when
people play the game they'll understand
what I mean and amenities is maybe a
good example of that I mean it's just
something or unstacking the cities that
you know those aspects of the game and
happiness and food they've they've been
in there but now they're presented in a
different way that actually kind of
makes more sense but also demands more
strategy right so then another one of
the changes we mentioned was the active
research what kind of strikes me is
almost one of the new side quest systems
because there are these things you can
pursue to either boost this science
research or this new technology
development but also sometimes you'll do
something on accident and then this new
tech will get a 50% boost like [ __ ] I
might as well go down that part of the
path now and maybe get to like riflemen
quicker can you talk about the research
yeah yeah so I mean yeah exactly as you
described you know it's civilization is
all about you know you have to you know
progress your civilization through
learning new technologies and we use new
technology you can build new units and
well all that kind of stuff so like
facilitating a scientific win or just
pushing toward like a cultural win with
like the specific text yeah but as you
said each new technology you can
research and each new Civic you can
research which we'll get into in a
minute has a specific caveat or
something about it that if you meet that
requirement it takes half the amount of
time to unlock it so yeah half mean can
mean like 10 to 20 turns reduced that's
such an amazing time-saver and it really
will allow you to leapfrog ahead of your
opponents if you can meet those
requirements
so yeah in certain cases I found myself
going out of my way to pursue a sir
and civic so that it would produce the
time it would take to unlock a certain
technology or things like that and yet
it does impact the way you strategize
it's not just like oh I'm gonna do the
exact same thing every time I know this
technology can let me build this unit
therefore I'm gonna do whatever it takes
to get to that immediately you kind of
have to play it by ear because certain
things just kind of come up organically
and as you pointed out that is one of
the just wonderful fantastic things
about sieve it really does reward
different playstyles and allow you to
win in different ways like I said I was
pursuing a cultural and scientific
victory I almost I built almost no
military units whatsoever the entire
game I barely upgraded anything my
cities were practically unprotected I I
made friends with everybody through
trade and diplomacy and just didn't
focus on military which helped me focus
instead on science so I mean again one
of the things that's just beautiful
about Civ one of the things that I have
noticed from my time playing the preview
builds the game I think I've played
about 15 hours of the game at this point
I've only finished one playthrough like
you it at this point but the barbarians
seemed both more aggressive and abundant
is that I mean you've only played one
playthrough so maybe next time the new
map will kind of mitigate their presence
but I hope so they are super obnoxious I
mean obviously barbarians have been part
of this series since day one and they
are one of the original ideas but yeah
they are not only smarter they're more
prevalent and they seem to just pop up
out of nowhere and they don't go away
the entire came there is an option to
turn barbarians off completely but I
really wish there was an option to just
reduce the number of barbarians because
the first probably 50 to 75 turns of the
game was just like oh my god I want to
get started but I have to fight off this
stupid brewery over and over like I know
they're Scout shows up I don't know
where like I said that was the the focus
of the game during the early chapters
which is I know kind of annoying to me
that's not the fun part of the game
that's like you know having to swat a
fly it's just this annoyance that's
buzzing around and right yeah I wish
they reduced that there were a few other
annoyances as well and I do characterize
them as annoyances most of the things I
encountered that I didn't like work on
the smaller side or just were smaller
issues in general a lot of it was just
weird UI stuff that I might need to get
used to like hovering over stuff in a
menu will cause a drop-down menu to open
but then that
so everything beneath it and there's
really no way to avoid it so I end up
having to like move the cursor around
like stupid little things like that
they're also some weird like I wouldn't
describe those technical hiccups but
things like I will click on the
technology tree and the game will kind
of freeze up for a second before it
opens there was an instance where I got
this warning that France was about to
win through a cultural victory but then
I checked the world score and they
clearly weren't so I don't know what
that was about yeah it was it was very
strange dang so yeah there are a few
minor annoyances like that that I'm
gonna dig into more in the text so if
anybody is watching this video on the
review and progress page you can read
the text to read more about exactly what
I'm talking about sure and then one more
thing I want to touch on before Hsu
kinda like closing broad questions sure
the Civic's how are those working this
time around cuz you mentioned them you
said you want to get into them yeah so
again it's an idea that's kind of been
in the game for a while or at least
sensitive five I mean social policies
were kind of a big part of say five or
that yeah and they're now presented
basically exactly the same ways
technology they operate in perfect
parallel technology you research them in
the same way it takes approximately same
amount of time it benefits you in a lot
of the same ways like you'll unlock new
governments through civic research as
opposed through technological research
so it's now presented identically just
different stuff and it actually makes
logical sense it's apart to like
separate the two I mean a hard technical
scientific advancement is not the same
thing as a civic advance it necessarily
so separating them into two different
pools that sort of function identically
actually makes a lot of sense and makes
the social policies just kind of more
understandable and feel a bit more
integrated into the experience sure so I
like I like that they did that that was
a smart choice cool is just kind of
further adding to like you said it's a
very much more active game overall right
totally
though that's the one last question I
kinda want to ask you is I think one big
thing would Civ games a lot of times
that first hundred fifty turns is always
the most fun and then you like sometimes
the mid-game you get pretty boring
sometimes the late-game victory rush
gets really boring when people are all
just like saddling up hoping they get to
that last turn to build a space station
or like you know found the World Bank
first but how did the flow of this game
feel I know there's only one playthrough
so you can't speak to the overall game
but for this playthrough how did like
the beginning middle end feel as opposed
to like severe live say no it is
important to point out as you just did
that this was a single playthrough and I
pursued a particular type of victory so
that's going to in
back to the way the game flowed that
said I I agree with something you
pointed out like a month ago and we were
talking about the game which is that the
mid game turns are definitely more
active and exciting than they have been
in previous games however I did still
hit the same kind of grind towards the
end where I'm just like okay I'm clearly
gonna win I just need to keep going I
need to like just hopefully no weird
curveball like nobody nukes me out of
nowhere or something I just had to grind
through it like I was building a space
station and just needed to finish and
needed to get through the turn so it
would actually complete so I do feel
like the particular playthrough that I
had didn't really crescendo in a
meaningful way but it was still it still
contained a lot of those like hallmark
big emotional moments of a sieve game of
just like when you start out just
feeling so overwhelmed by the world and
like overwhelm of the possibilities of
it and getting really excited when your
strategy starts to pay off and starts to
see things actually get builds and
things like that
so a lot of those beats are still in
there even if it did kind of grind to a
halt towards the end sure okay cool so I
mean obviously it's a civilization gave
you a lot to parse through about twelve
hours you have a lot more to play before
you go a full review but totally at the
time of this video being published you
have a review and progress up in the
site you'll be able to hear more in
depth your thoughts are like on those
first twelve hours but until next time
I'm sure you'll be playing a lot and
then we can kind of hear your final
thoughts at some point yeah sometime
next week more than likely I mean again
it's a game you play for hundreds of
hours which I don't know how many
hundreds of hours I have to put into
this during holiday season but I'm
excited to play more definitely excited
yeah I'm excited to play too thanks so
much got absolutely
you